Welcome to the video on
the introduction to
differential equations.
What's a differential?
Well, we've been doing things
like if I said that y is
equal to, I don't know, 3x.
If we took the derivative of
both sides of this equation and
we said -- one of the notations
we used is we said dy
over dx is equal to 3.
We took the derivative
of both sides of that.
But this you could almost
use differential notation.
dy is a differential and
dx is a differential.
What does a differential mean?
A differential just means an
infinitely small change in y,
in this case, so that's a
differential in y, or an
infinitely small change in x.
So a differential it's like a
difference -- when we learned
slope, we said slope is change
in y over change in x.
Or you could say the difference
in y over difference in x.
But once we started taking the
slope of curves we had to make
this difference and this
difference approach 0.
That's what a differential
essentially is.
A differential is a really,
really, really, really
infinitely small difference.
So what is a
differential equation?
Well it's an equation that
involves differentials.
So, for example, this is
a differential equation.
This will be the first
example that we solve.
dy over dx is equal
to x squared plus 1.
So how do we solve this
differential equation?
Well, there's a couple of
ways you could say it.
You say oh, well this is the
same thing as f prime of x.
You know, y to the function
of x and you just take the
antiderivative of both sides.
But let's solve this properly
as a differential equation.
So you can actually manipulate
these differentials the same
way that you would manipulate
numbers for the most part.
And so what could we do here?
Let's multiply both sides
of this equation by dx.
So you get, for a very small
change in y, dy, you get x
squared plus 1 times a very
small change in the x.
Or another way to say it is for
a very small change in x, if
you want to figure out how much
does y change, you multiply
times x squared plus 1 wherever
you are on the curve.
So what does that do for us?
Well let's take the
antiderivative of both
sides or let's take the
integral of both sides.
And if you watched all of the
videos on integration and the
definite integral and area and
a curve, you realize that an
integral is essentially a sum,
it's kind of an infinite
sum of a bunch of these
infinitely small dy's.
So if you take the sum of
all of the changes in dy's,
you're left with a y on
this side of this equation.
You might want to re-watch
all the videos that we
did on integration.
Then what is this?
This is essentially just
-- this is the indefinite
integral of x squared plus 1.
So it's the
antiderivative of that.
And what's the antiderivative
of x squared plus 1?
Well it's x to the
third over 3.
We're just taking the
derivative backwards.
And once again, watch the
videos on the antiderivative.
There's I think eight
or nine of them.
Plus x and then plus c.
And where does the c come from?
Well we know that when we
take the derivative of a
constant it goes to 0.
So when you take the
antiderivative, we're like
well, there could have
been a constant there.
And that's where that
plus c comes from.
So this is the general solution
to this differential equation.
And that's something
interesting.
So with traditional equations,
the solution tended to
be a number, right?
If I just told you y is
equal to 2y minus 1.
Then you would get minus y
is equal to minus 1, you'd
get y is equal to 1.
So this is a traditional
equation and your solution
was just a value -- you
solved for the variable.
Differential equations
are something different.
The solution is
actually a function.
You're saying what
function satisfies this
differential equation.
So that's something
to keep in mind.
Right now we're doing very
basic differential equations,
but that's something to keep in
mind the whole time you learn
differential equations.
I think I'll eventually do
a play list on essentially
an introductory course on
differential equations that
you would take at college.
And that applies even when
you start doing partial
differential equations,
et cetera, et cetera.
The solution to a differential
equation is not a number,
it is a function.
So anyway, this was the
general solution to this
differential equation.
And if you want the particular
solution, people normally give
you initial conditions or they
give you points on the function
and then you can
substitute back.
In this problem they said that
dy dx equals x squared plus 1.
And they said that -- let me
switch colors -- they said that
y is equal to 1 at x is equal
to 1, or y is equal to 1
when x is equal to 1.
So we can use this information
now to solve for c.
How do you do that?
Well it says y is equal to 1.
So 1 is equal to when x is
equal to 1, is equal to 1/3,
right, 1 over 3, 1 to the third
power over 3, plus 1 plus c.
And let's see what I can do.
Subtract one from both
sides -- this comes 0.
Subtract 1/3 from both
sides and you get c is
equal to minus 1/3.
So using these conditions, a
point where this function
crosses through, we can now
give you the particular
solution to this
differential equation.
And that is y is equal to x to
the third over 3 plus x minus
1/3, and then we just
solve for the c.
And if you don't believe me,
take this expression and
substitute it here and you will
see that it equals, if you were
to take the derivative of y
with respect to x, you would
see that it equals
x squared plus 1.
Let's do another one.
So it tells us -- so this is a
little bit more interesting --
it says dy dx is equal to
x over y, and it has
the same conditions.
It says y equals
1 at x equals 1.
Or when x equals 1, y equals 1.
So let's find the function
that satisfies this equation.
This one's interesting because
we have an x and a y on
the right hand side
of the equation.
So this kind of looks like
something we got after we
did some type of implicit
differentiation.
But let's see where we go.
So let's do the same thing.
Let's multiply both sides of
this equation by dx until you
get dy is equal to x over y dx.
And let's get this y over
onto the dy side, because
it will be easy to take
the antiderivative then.
So we get y dy is
equal to x dx.
Now we can take the integral of
both sides of this equation, or
take the antiderivative on this
side with respect to y on
the side with respect to x.
I don't know why I
did it in brown.
So what's the
antiderivative here?
Well, it is y squared over 2.
And I could say plus
c, some constant.
Let me do that.
There could be a constant here.
I'll call it c1.
We don't know what
that constant is.
And that equals x squared
over 2 plus c2, right?
Or some other constant.
Maybe it's the same
number, I don't know.
But we don't know what
either of these are.
I could re-write it as --
let's see, what could I do?
Let me take the x
out of that side.
So I could have y squared over
2 minus x squared over 2 is
equal to -- and let me subtract
this from that side so I get
the constants all on the right
hand side of the equation.
c2 minus c1.
I just took a c1, put it on the
right hand side, took the x
squared over 2, put it on the
left hand side, that's
why it's negative.
And we didn't know.
We said this could be
any constant and this
could be any constant.
So the difference between two
arbitrary constants could just
be a third arbitrary constant.
So I'll just
re-write that as c.
So the general solution to this
differential equation is y
squared over 2 minus x squared
over 2 is equal to c.
Actually let's do something
else just to clean it up a
little bit, because once again
this could be any constant.
So let's multiply both sides
of this equation by 2 and
you get y squared minus
x squared equal to 2c.
Well now this is still any
constant number, so we could
still write this as a c.
So we have y squared minus
x squared is equal to c.
Now let's use our initial
conditions to see what c is.
So when y is 1, so 1 squared
minus when x is 1, 1 squared is
equal to c, this is 1 minus 1,
so it's 0, right?
c is equal to 0.
So what is the particular
solution to this
differential equation?
I'll do it in green.
It is y squared minus x
squared is equal to 0.
Or we could add x squared
to both sides of that.
We could also write it as y
squared is equal to x squared.
Now you might be tempted to
take the square root of both
sides of this and say
that y is equal to x.
The reason why this would not
be accurate is because here x
could be minus 2 and y could
be plus 2 or vice versa.
So this would satisfy this
equation, but it would not
satisfy this equation.
So be careful when you
take that square root.
You have to worry about
the plus or minus.
Let's do one more.
So this one says the derivative
of y with respect to x is equal
to -- OK, so this is even a
little bit more interesting.
This is equal to the
square root of x over y.
And it says that y is equal
to 4 when is equal to 1.
Yup, I think I'm
reading that right.
We could do this one
very similarly.
So let's just do the same step.
So multiply both sides of
the equation times dx.
So you get dy is equal to --
and just to skip a step, I'm
going to re-write square root
of x over y is the square root
of x over the square root
of y, and I multiply both
sides of that times dx.
Now let's multiply both
sides of this equation
by the square root of y.
And I'm just going to re-write
it as y to the 1/2 power.
That's the same thing as
the square root of y.
dy is equal to x to
the 1/2 power dx.
I just multiplied that
there and re-wrote
it as y to the 1/2.
So what is the antiderivative
of y to the 1/2 power?
Well it's just this plus 1, so
it's y the 3/2 power, and then
times the inverse of this.
So times 2/3.
Or you could have said
divided by this, either way.
And if you're not sure about
this, because sometimes it is
confusing with the fractions
and whatever else,
take the derivative.
3/2 times 2/3 is 1, and then
you subtract this 1 from
the exponent and you
get y to the 1/2.
So that works.
And of course, we kind of go
through the same drill, plus c1
is equal to -- it's going to be
the same thing on this side
-- 2/3 x to the 3/2 plus
c2, and what can we do?
Well let's take the x to the
left hand side of this
equation, so we get 2/3 y to
the 3/2 minus 2/3 x to the 3/2
is equal to c2 minus c1, which
we can just re-write as c.
And let's multiply both sides
of this equation by 3/2, so
these two will become 1.
So you get y to 3/2 minus x to
the 3/2 is equal to -- well
what's 3/2 times
some constant c.
But we didn't even know what
it was, we haven't solved for
it, so we can still write c.
I hope that doesn't
confuse you.
3/2 c, we didn't
know what it was.
We could call this c3
and now this is c4.
It's a different constant, but
we still have to solve for it.
And now let's use our
initial conditions.
So the initial conditions tell
us that 4 -- and they don't
have to be initial conditions.
You can kind of say conditions
or points where we know that
the particular solution to this
differential equation
are satisfied.
So 4 to the 3/2 minus 1 to
the 3/2 is equal to c.
What's 4 to the 3/2?
So 4 to the 1/2 is 2, and then
that to the 3 power, that's 8.
Then 1 to any power, but
especially in this case, 1 to
the square root of 1 is 1.
Then to the third power is 1.
So 8 minus 1 is equal to c.
And so c is equal to 7.
So the particular solution of
this differential equation I
will do in a different color,
and it is y to the 3/2 minus
x to the 3/2 is equal to 7.